foreign
is with us in Cheyenne Wyoming hi
Christine how are you
great how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
um thank you so much for taking my call
so my husband and I are new listeners of
yours and
um we're on baby steps fourth item six
we have no debt except for our mortgage
good but we're concerned that our
mortgage is a bit High it doesn't quite
follow your ratios so I just wanted to
talk that through with you and see us we
should keep going on there's make a
change
okay in this case our ratios uh
don't matter as much in the case of
mortgage payment as a percentage of your
income as why
we have the ratios now that matters a
lot okay the why is simply uh if you use
up all your money on your house payment
you don't have any money it's called
House poor
right
and that will cause you with if you're
if you're living with a super high house
payment even though you're already out
of debt and you're baby step four five
and six it'll keep you from investing
long term keep you from your generosity
goals and it in some cases if it's super
high if for people people feel forced uh
to take a car payment because they don't
save up for a car because I don't have
any room to save up for a car or
something like that so that's the reason
we tell people to not get a super high
house payment like most of the culture
tells you to do that and so once you
kind of understand that then you can
kind of back into your particulars
and say you know okay what do we what
are we violating on the 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed and um
and how is that going to be okay given
that we don't want to be house poor so
how much is your house payment
3 900
say again
3 900.
and your monthly take-home pay is
11 000.
okay so you're about 34 percent
right okay and um
what do you guys do for a living
uh my husband is in supply chain is what
and I say he's in supply chain and I
stay home with our kids
supply chain oh look I can't hear okay
um supply chain
all right and uh
he's killing it
um
so
how many raises now that because last
two years don't count what do you guys
feel like the trajectory of his income
is
is it going to go up substantially in
the next three years
I think so which makes this conversation
not needed moot right
okay yeah because I mean if it goes from
33 to 28 to 25 percent with three raises
because your house payment stays the
same and your income goes up then we're
not worried about you being house poor
long term correct
correct yeah so that that's one fix for
this but if you had two wild years based
on supply chain backup and he crushed it
and he's going to settle back into 9 000
a month now you got a problem exactly
so what are you looking at on his income
do you think
I think it'll go out
yeah
if it goes down you need to reevaluate
this house
okay if it as long as it is has an
upward trajectory in the next 36 to 48
months you're not going to be stuck
there with all your money going to a
house payment and not be able to fund
your kids college fund
or having an air conditioner break and
you got to get it go to a credit union
to get to be able to pay for it right
right
that's right that's right yeah so just
don't get yourself to where you're there
that's the whole point of the thing you
see uh and yeah so you don't you don't
need Ramsay to tell you how to manage
your life you just but you but A good
rule period whether Ramsay's in your
discussion or not is don't be house poor
don't have a house payment that takes up
all your money makes you broke and so uh
but I think you sound like you're okay
it's not ideal if you were getting ready
to buy a home I would tell you to back
off don't be so house uh you know but
you're there I wouldn't tell you to move
over this you're not trapped and
hopelessly
mathematically disabled you know
so I wouldn't tell you to do that but uh
but you don't have any room it's got to
go up uh it can't go back and you don't
have any wiggle room because if it gets
if it goes down much it stays down very
long you're going to be forced into a
different property but right now I think
you got a lot of house and in Cheyenne
Wyoming it's a big freaking house
that's a big dog right there well done
good for you I bet it's fun